and we're playing floor bogger
11 12 and let's go for another danish
gambit
let's go for another danish gambit
oh and we've faced this once before guys
that is not good
that is not good at all and you guys
know why by now if he takes he's busted
you probably will recognize it oh god oh
no we've done that actually once before
yeah this is damiano without the night
sacrifice and the damiano we have the
same position
in the absence of the g1 knight here we
have the knight on the board and we win
the rook in the game
we are literally following the game that
we had previously
yeah and i'm not commenting this because
it's pretty evident
yeah he's busted
boom goodbye
knight is hanging he moves his king we
can get this guy
let's get this baby out to c4
yeah it's over
yeah okay i'm playing another one and we
are 1100.
so you guys can see the danish game
gambit i mean it's people below 13 1400
really don't know what to do against it
and um yeah f6
do take c5 now at this point if you've
blundered something like this and that's
another thing that i want to make clear
one of the key uh abilities that you can
cultivate as early as beginner level is
you recognized oh my god i played this
move
don't be embarrassed but try to make the
most of the situation let's say you were
black
and you wanted to make the most of the
situation what would you do
how does black avoid getting an
immediately lost position
you don't need to play queen e7 right
that's a bit of a panicky reaction
simply nice season exactly 19 resign
that's a great call knight c6
and get white to take the pawn so at
least you get your knights out you've
got a reasonable position here actually
so that's uh something that you could do
um d6 where
yeah okay um so anyways guys we'll get
one more gaming
all right we got another white game
against uh luca de aborte now we've
no we haven't faced i think a single
move other than e5
sure
no freaking way i swear these are not
paid actors
there is no way that this is happening
again all my lands
oh my lands oh my
hands you can't script this
oh my god that's crazy
and here we're up a qui i rook in a
piece in an end game
i'm gonna go knight d5 and go after his
pawn
that's insane the danish can't be beat
you guys should be taking it up
right about now if you're in this rating
range
you don't need a gm to deliver these
moves but let's stay on task i'm just
going to complete my development in
castle
i'm not even commenting these moves i'm
just developing
yeah castles now
okay nitpicky question what should we do
nitpicky question what should we do
yeah i'll show you guys what to do at
some point take and simplify what should
we take with
if you've got good good tactical vision
you will see that
upon taking you create the possibility
of a discovered
check and the best way to pave the way
for that is to take with the bishop and
not with the knight
because it doesn't matter here because
we're up so many pieces but if you take
with the knight
and he takes with the pawn he attacks
the bishop which dilutes the
effectiveness of a discover check here
you can give it on b6
and take the rook on aa and remember
when i was training qt cinderella she
would do something like knight takes c7
here
which is the right idea but this be
careful that you don't allow
a piece that's um that's in a discovered
checklist
i mean the king to move away from the
discovery check and take the piece
that's
trying to uh you know what i'm saying
like trying to make the rock
okay i'm gonna go a4 here i'm gonna try
to uh get the bishop out to b5
check and
okay again i'm not even commenting this
i'm just gonna try and i'm just gonna
try to mate with a pawn c3 before mate
yeah that's me i have a nice mate i got
to say what
would an amazing win okay
so we we got to get one more and after
this one that was ridiculous
um nothing to commentate here we just
develop our people but notice that i'm
developing my pieces like all i'm doing
after i win all this is just to develop
my pieces and
centralize my night so the paradoxical
thing is that
uh the vast majority of the time i'm
actually not playing too creatively
or too aggressively i'm following the
rules most of the time i'm following the
rules
um but the times when you don't follow
the rules are
what makes chess such a magical game
okay
what happens if he just brings out
knight after our first two pawn moves
well we face that like we face knight c6
a couple of times and we take on e5
and if he goes knight f6 which we have
faced once we get
this position and i think that
bishop c4 we faced this as well so
that'll be all on youtube
we got to get one more game and guys
this is getting ridiculous
engage armenian player 11 10.
let's go d5 facing d4 for the first time
now there are many openings that we
could play we've been playing the
queen's camera declined
but i would like to introduce you guys
to the to the nimzo indian here
okay the names of indian i would say
along with the queen's gamut decline is
among the most solid and reputable
positional openings you could play
and in the nimso you play bishop before
and i'll talk a little bit about the
nomenclature
um after the game but you see what
happens
at this level people aren't prepared for
it he goes e4 reasonable move he
controls the center
he doesn't understand you know he
doesn't ask himself what was the point
of bishop before though
which was to pin the knight what should
we do
thank you vladimir i really appreciate
it now some of you are making
an instructive mistake you don't need to
take on c3 first you just eat the pawn
it is far more flexible to do this maybe
later you'll take on c3 with the bishop
but also maybe not you're actually in
there we go now we take with the knight
and we've already basically won the game
so
if you and this is hopefully i'm
justifying something i've been saying
for a long time which is that
there is a myth that circulates around
many corners of chess coaching
i believe it's a myth and i believe that
this myth says
essentially that you don't need to do
openings if you're like under 1600.
hopefully i'm showing that if you do do
openings
um below 1600 that the benefits that you
can reap from that
all right now what should we do and here
we need to be careful he doesn't take
the knife back
clearly we don't actually even really
need to move the knife
but let's move it just for clarity and
when you're talking about a discovered
check you just need to
brute force it look at every square that
the knight can go to and figure it out
well knight takes a2 comes to mind
that's that's a pretty good pun but then
he goes bishop to d2 right
and he was bishop to d2 and we're gonna
have to deal with that knight
and evacuate it there is a more classy
move
okay knight a4 check does that do
anything no not not really right
knight d5 check not really not really 92
and 91 blunder
blunder the knight but what about knight
b5 check wait a second let's think about
that for a second oh
that attacks d4 so not only do we win a
pawn but we also
evacuate and recentralize the knight
brute force method we just
okay so first let's let's take drag his
king out and now we take on d4
so sometimes when you've got to discover
check literally brute force it look at
every legal move every legal discover
check
um that doesn't take that long it sounds
very cumbersome but
it's it's not at all in many cases all
right
so this one is basically over
okay he's attacking two pieces at the
same time pawn in the knight
what do we do
yeah queen f6 boom boom
simple defensive move knight f5 would
not be as effective he would take that
knight
okay knight f3 here i'm not going to ask
you guys i think it's pretty
pretty obvious that we can take the
knight and snag another pawn on b2
this is a great application of the
concept that we don't need to always
go crazy about queen trade thoughts
about tonight um when we're off material
if an opportunity to attack or to win
more material or presents itself there's
no reason not to go for it
now if he goes rook b1 here which i
think he will and i think he'll do it
probably with this rook
i know these players pretty well by now
i can see the wheels turning in his head
um
what should we do now so now we have us
what what a
i would call a simplifying combination
we have a simplifying combination
how do we find it a lot of you guys are
seeing it knight d4
would be a fork boom this is
very rudimentary stuff knight t4 check
and i takes f3
we simplify by trading queens and a pair
of minor pieces and we ruin a structure
now what should we do with this bishop
hey dunlops
what would be the most efficient way of
developing this bishop and
this is very common in the nimzo it is
very common in the nimzo because
when we play e6 we create a pawn chain
that often
delay makes it hard to develop the
bishop along the standard route
so not only do we find keto let's bring
it to a6 so it skewers the pawn to the
acting on that skewer with d5 and
winning the pawn
now this is all kind of pedantic at this
point because we're so winning
but okay let's go c5 let's push this one
in he's probably gonna go kingdom five
and then he's gonna get checkmated there
um
how now this is instructive what do we
do
how do we actually mate him or set up
the mate
all right good job g7 now he can play f5
and prolong the game i hope he doesn't
yeah
mate with the pawn again so names of
indian ladies and gentlemen
a little bit of chess history who was
the first person to play the nemazonian
was it in fact aaron
nimsovich so a word on the nomenclature
i know this confuses a lot of people
this is the nimzo indian okay
nimzo indian depends on white playing
knight c3
if white does not play knight c3 you
will not have an enzo indian
okay um so
it was first played in the year 1851 by
banerjee
indian player mohichunder bonerji
against british player john cochran and
um
it was played by names of which but nims
which was only the seventh player
to play the name zodian and alakine
against rubenstein
played the nimzo indian in the very same
tournament
one round before so maybe there was a
little bit of plagiarism going on
i think we're uncovering something kind
of interesting here
in 1914 at a tournament in saint
petersburg alekhine played
the nimzo indian in uh round five
against rubenstein
only the sixth player to do so and the
seventh player to do so was
the day after that with nimzovich very
interesting
stuff going on okay anyways it's called
the names of indian also because aaron
nemesevich analyzed this in his books
um now white can go knight f3
and in this position there are many
systems you can play the queen's indian
i've played that that's b6
you can play the rogozin so you can play
d5
and now bishop e7 transposes to the uh
queen's gambit declined
that's also possible but there goes in
his bishop before here
i know that this is confusing you guys
wait a minute isn't this the nimzo
indian not quite
because you have the addition of these
two moves all right
so and finally white has the catalan and
that is g3 in this position the dreaded
catalan
and again there's a million systems here
usually white starts with knight f3
um and then i'm not going to delve into
them okay
so rogozin after vichy's lava goes yeah
okay so here he plays the nimzo
and e4 is a mistake
now the nimzo indian is an opening
that bases its um
effectiveness on and i don't want to
keep citing that but hyper modern
principles yes
because black only controls a little bit
of the center and in fact black refrains
from d5 a lot of the time
instead preferring to fiance of the
bishop and what i want you guys to see
let's say that white plays kind of
normally
look at how much of a central control
black species have the knight and the
bishop both
staring at e4 um and doing it from a
distance
and one of the beautiful things about
the nimzo is that
you often get in situations where every
single piece
is um coordinated in a subtle way with
the other pieces
and not none of the pieces are
interfering with each other
like bishop is controlling the open
diagonal knights are connected pawns are
nice and solid and this bishop
doing some pressuring on the queen side
so it is um
a very harmonious opening and that's why
it's withstood the test of time and it
remains
you know one of the best openings in
general
all right um now our opponent
blundered very quickly knight takes c3
and everything else was very very simple
all right any questions
what is it oh good question what exactly
is a system and how does it differ from
a setup so
um a system in relation to a chess
opening
like the london system um the king's
indian attack
is also a system i prefer the use of of
system
to refer specifically to a set of moves
that you make
virtually against every response by the
opponent
okay the london system is a system
because within reasonable limits now
you're
like were you five and you wouldn't play
bishop for but against most moves you
play
the same general system um in the king's
indian attack it's much the same thing
and uh you know so i would actually
think that's a pretty
good um way of thinking about certain
openings like which openings are more
systematic
uh some openings are more systematic
than other openings all right
um like king's indian for black is a
pretty pretty systematic oh i wouldn't
call it a system
but it's it's a pretty systematic
opening um
so that's just uh all i would say and
the setup isn't really a formal
opening word kind of thing all right
and this goes to why i think the london
does hinder a beginner's development
because when you play a pure system
opening
you literally play the same moves
against everything you don't
expend your um
you know your circle of understanding
that's the bottom line here
okay
well you know what i have to say here
i'm tempted to do one more
okay
let's do it last one but this this is
the actual lesson because i gotta sleep
before my commentary
all right and we got lad 55
russian player now we're getting serious
and let's go for another caro con
there's a knight f3 this time define
doesn't change what we do
last game chat
e5 all right
so this is uh possible
and but because he's played the knight
uh to f3
he's given us the extra option of
bringing the bishop out to g4
which is generally not um not possible
um uh because because the queen controls
that square
is it worth it yeah i think it's worth
it why not
why not uh bishop geforce that seems
like a great improvement even to bishop
f5
thank you boomer housing for the prime
thank you so much i appreciate it and
what should we do now guys
whoa we got a dono three bucks from
amir uh karabeg thank you so much the
way you explain everything is so clear
and clever i appreciate it man
yeah e6 the fact that he's playing this
passively doesn't change doesn't alter
what we do
what now so
remember knight d7 is possible but not
strictly necessary
instead we can go c5 and then go knight
c6 that is the optimal way of developing
what do we do now what's the thematic
move
yeah we take all right it's time to take
because already
we've destroyed virtually destroyed as
pawn chain
and we can take on d4 immediately
but the classy move
is to play knight c6 to withhold
withhold that let him
do the taking trading on our own terms
again
ryan gifting to zephyry and look at how
now our bishop has developed his pawn is
still very weak we're going to win that
pawn
in fact he doesn't put up any resistance
we're just going to take it
all right
bishop b2 what do we do now
yeah queen a5 was fine
so we don't have to reinvent the wheel
here don't have to reinvent the wheel
knight f6
okay so he he wants b4
and because we're playing this very
positionally um
now we could play a5 here and stop it
but
we don't actually need to do that
because b4 is not dangerous we can just
move our bishop
and another thing that players that you
know this level don't always factor in
are squares
i've talked about weak squares already
right what square does this weaken
and where should we put our bishop now
we can put it on d6 or b6 both are good
i like putting it on d6
yeah look at this juicy juicy square the
reason we put it on d6 is very simple
after he plays
okay had he played bishop b2 he would
not have been attacking our knight
and now we have also a more aggressive
plan connected with building a battery
here but
in the name of positional chess
how do we increase our control over the
c4 square
rook c8 but before we even do that let
me really um
annoy you guys we can improve the
situation on the queen side
in a way that we've done before i've
made this move before this bond sticks
out like a sore thumb
when i see this construction i
immediately start thinking of
undermining right when you undermine
stuff
you try to break down this pawn
structure it's very vulnerable because
he hasn't completed his development boom
he's in a lose-lose spot if he takes
if he goes b5 well that creates another
hole on c5
that pawn on a3 because his entire
position just sort of starts to crumble
a little bit further
and if he goes c3 well then he pays the
price for not having developed the
knight his rook is undefended
a takes b4 c takes b4 and i've shown you
guys this before bishop takes b4
um so he takes well now we can bring the
queen out right
and perhaps we can even bring the other
rook to c8 so that the the a8 rook
is now um fulfilling a pretty important
role
okay bishop d2
where should we put our queen every one
of these decisions
may seem insignificant but it's
important
and we have to keep our eyes on the
prize we know what we want we want to
increase our hold over c
over uh c4 and we also want to
potentially pressure the pawn so queen
c78 is
all right i did kind of overlook knight
c3
which would aim for b5 it's not an issue
though
but the yeah knight c3 he played now
i actually will be honest with you guys
i didn't realize that this comes with
tempo and i i really don't want to part
ways with this bishop
i really don't want to part ways with
this bishop okay
why why don't why don't i want to part
ways with it well
let me write this down um
why not allow knight b5
but one of them is that the bishop is
the instrument
that allows us to attack the pawn and
it's just the glue guy bishop is the
glue guy
rook a5 is um not effective because he
still goes knight p5 that bishop defends
the square if we take on a3
we still allow him to play knight b5 and
i
it gets complicated you guys should be
able to see that
so what do we do are we are we busted
here no we're not
uh we just need to take the opposite
perspective we're
looking at this from the angle of
physically stopping knight b5 but let's
take the sting out of it
let's take this thing out of it what
that means is moving one of these two
pieces so that knight p5 doesn't
act as kind of a soft fork and we want
to take this thing out of it preferably
without ruining the placement of the
pieces maybe even improving it
and bishop e7 would worsen the situation
of the bishop but bishop c5 would not
all right hope the logic makes sense we
could have also the other move i thought
of
yeah queen e7 or queen c6 and
you guys see how effective this thinking
is we just go queen c6
we're good our bishop is still great and
this knight is now dangling on b5 doing
absolutely nothing okay he supports it
with a4
in fact not only is it doing nothing but
when a move like that is made i consider
its drawbacks what squares
does it no longer control again always
asking yourself that question when a
piece goes to this from the center to
the side of the board
it relinquishes control of certain but
not a4 sorry guys
i meant the move knight b5 right knight
e4 centralizing
thank you tommy i really appreciate it
it's very sweet
all right
okay so bishop e3
now i said that we don't want to part
ways with our bishop that was true then
that was then this is now and the
circumstances have changed he's offering
us
a much better deal we can ruin his
structure
weaken his king create an isolated pawn
and get rid of his dark squared bishop
i'm fine with that
hp that's the thing with the front here
um i think some of you might be thinking
of moves like night g3
we don't need to decide on that yet we
can make a general improving move
gem yeah we can go knight c3 trade oh
that's a good move
that's a fantastic move actually good
thinking guys
trading his strongest piece yes for our
strongest piece
true but remember we've also got the
other centralized knight
so it's not a you know he's only got one
good piece we've got
a bunch of good pieces so this this
makes a lot of sense perfect
curious to tommy thank you
queen attacking the pawn no we're not
concerned about the felt and again i
hearken you back to the worst case
scenario test
even if we allowed him to do everything
he wanted how could he possibly
have enough firepower to attack this
bond so here
we want to be clinical okay he's just
giving us the pawn we can go queen e3
and take with the pawn but i actually
like
taking it with the pawn because this
creates a far advanced passer and it
opens the d file
who's going to control that default it's
definitely going to be us
okay so open files are overrated i'll
talk about that in a second
yeah i i'm going to talk about a very
important concept afterwards
to nado again damn girl another three i
run a startup out of uc berkeley nice
nice okay so which rook should we go to
d8 with
which rook should we go to d8 with yeah
the rook on f8 lends some support to the
f1 why
risk it why risk it um let's go with the
uh va rook okay
now there's a distinction to be made
between like things that you know are
going to happen versus things that
you're doing just to be safe
this is something you're doing to be
safe probably nothing would have
happened if we'd gone rook fda
but i just want to make sure that that
this rook uh
supervises this for abundance to say
okay so he attacks the queen
okay um
where should we go we can offer a queen
trade but if we're offering a queen
trade we better do it actively boom
queen d2 fine take our queen
but you're gonna be making our rook
incredibly active look at how it
connects with our previous move we could
have also gone queen c5 check that would
have been fine as well
there were alternatives there were
alternatives
no i usually like your moves it attacks
the bishop
and now we need to start thinking a
little bit about how to improve the
position further
well it stems logically from the fact
that we have
a bunch of extra pawns most of them are
on the king side
we should probably consider pushing them
we can't push e3
nor do we need to we can actually snag a
third pawn but we don't even need to do
that
let's get down to business to defeat the
huns
yeah rocket is possible but we can play
more directly
we can play more directly we have a
bunch of these pawns
at some point you can just say all right
i'm just gonna start pushing these guys
and look at how our knight is right in
the center it's completely dominating
over the bishop
um f4 now you don't just want to put
your head down literally just like
um willy nilly helps her skelter go
crazy
in fact you want to want to uh exercise
tremendous degree of caution
what is the idea of rook c3 where is the
stroke potentially going
let's play this without giving him any
chances at all zero
it's maybe going to c5 and i don't want
to leave i don't want this knight to
leave
e5 bingo prophylaxis b-town pro thank
you
these moves drive your opponent crazy
all right
um he can go to c7 but that doesn't do
anything that one rook in isolation
is going to accomplish nothing and
i know that that might not be obvious
but
if you look at it more carefully what is
it even going to threaten he's probably
going to go here yes
but this comes in way too late what can
we do now
yeah it is accepted once you have an end
game we could just keep pushing right
and which of these should we keep
pushing
so you guys are thinking of defending
the pawn but look at how far these are
advanced yet just f3 i mean the game is
over
the game is over because we're just
gonna take this pawn
we're actually going for checkmate we're
not necessarily only going for promotion
we're also going for checkmate
and yeah
so like okay he takes that's a good move
now we take
and now we need one final maneuver to
win the game now we don't want to move
the knight
i really don't want to move the knight
because if we do um
if we do then then we drop the e4 pawn
not a disaster
so how can we um prevent that from being
gone okay five simple
making sure that this isn't made you
know king f7 yeah
and now this rook we notice the fact
that his king is out of squares
our mating sort of detection patterns
begin to activate
and we notice that we can okay so he
blunders just gives us this
that would be the best option rook h5
would have been the idea yes
okay
so the funny thing is a good way to
practice the sam shanghai question right
a lot of people have the instinct of
moving the knight
this is where my instinct from you guys
are is different my instinct is not to
move the knight but to first check
whether i can play rook h5
anyway and i can and it's not hard to
calculate this rook d7 king e6
and mate is unstoppable not because
you're attacking white syrup but because
even if you weren't it would be
unstoppable
yeah but it's a good practice to move
the game closer to the center
making sure there is no stalemate
because he's got pawn moves at his
disposal just something to note to
yourself
and the game is over
okay that was a good opponent we're
we're getting up there
so e4 a5 bishop g4 blah blah so c5
we do all the normal karakan things
bishop c5 the first part of the game
should be
very very clear to everybody okay so we
allow b4
and i think that some players also have
this
extreme where they either try to prevent
every single thread or they don't look
for threats
sometimes you say okay b4 is his idea
but
i'm going to allow it there's no need to
stop everything your opponent wants to
do sometimes it makes more harm than
good
okay bishop d6 um a5 should make sense
to everybody right
a5 should make sense to everybody
take stakes
queen c7 dropping it back now if i had
seen this maybe i've got
queen v6 but it doesn't really matter
now bishop c5 getting the bishop out of
the
um out of the range of the knight i am
bowman thank you for the
gift of fast eric queen c6 please
explain a5
well i did that during the game to recap
five is
called undermining undermining is when
you essentially um try to
force him to push upon and in doing so
to create further structural and
positional weaknesses what does that
mean
well think about it this way the move b5
it extends the influence of the bishop
it weakens the c5 square
and just visually it softens up the
entire queen side
and if he doesn't take a5 then we take
b4 and we win a pawn
all right could we have when d4 with a
bishop
oh well but the queen guard is that
square
right or is that not the moment i wish
you wanted to do that
so does that make sense let's move on
now don't over apply this but that's the
point
okay so boom boom boom knight e4
centralizing
okay why spend moves undermining the
side of your castle too
well the answer is that you don't you
wouldn't chess game ultimately through
checkmate
but you you can attack the side of the
board
um opposite his king right that's
called a queenside attack and that's
perfectly otherwise the king's indian
would just be losing for white because
white attacks on
the opposite side of the board so
the end result of that is just to win
material on that side or to
blast things open right by definition
those kinds of attacks are harder to
execute often
than king side than attacks on the king
because you can't quite notice your
target
what makes people uncomfortable about
these kinds of attacks
is the absolute seeming absence of a
target
when you're attacking the king you know
exactly um
uh what you're attacking when you attack
the opposite side of the board you don't
really know what you're doing or what
you're going for
and you should abstract that a little
bit you shouldn't be thinking of it in
terms of
one target you should be thinking of it
as sort of a side of the board you're
trying to
either create weaknesses or win material
you don't always need a specific target
okay so knight e4
bishop d3 now we trade his strongest
piece and
d takes e4 everything we did was very
straightforward here
i didn't make a single move that should
be confusing
if any of them were please ask me to
explain now b6 unnecessary but kind of
nice prophylaxis preventing him from
going rook c5 and that's the top
computer move guys actually
that is the top computer computers think
prophylactic all the time
and i can i reckon my i reckon my um
accuracy here is pretty high actually
let's check
um not to like not trying to toot my own
horn here but like
what i want to show is to the country i
want to show you that you were able to
come up with all these moves as well
yeah good 96.
so you don't need to play extraordinary
hs
to play a good game okay
i will too my horn that was a really
nice game
all right um of course
if you played queen e7 before knight b5
would you have played bishop a3 well
here's the thing
um if we take on a3 and after an ip5 b
you can play like this yes but i would
go so far as to say
i did not want to give up the bishop
even for another pawn
even for another pawn because
he can go something like queen b1 and
he's attacking b7 and he's threatening
the skewer
and this creates some confusion so
i feel like that would not be worth my
while
all right okay